okay so suppose that you are reading
hacker news and on Monday you see
somebody post c3j s ad three based
reusable charts library so like okay
whatever and then on Wednesday somebody
posts Chartist JavaScript based reusable
charts so that's a little bit strange
right and then on Sunday somebody posts
dimple.js
easy and flexible d3 charting so what
and you google it and you find okay
there's a Wikipedia page comparing 30
different JavaScript charting frameworks
and then there's a blog post comparing
50 JavaScript library for charts and the
blog post is two years old so what and
okay okay there might be one reasonable
explanation for this maybe all of these
libraries are doing really different
things like surely we're not just making
the same charts over and over again but
then you start looking at the websites
and a sinking feeling sets in when you
realize that actually they're all doing
the same thing seriously what do we just
really like reinventing the pie chart so
if we're going to get to the bottom of
this we pretty much need to look at a
library called d3 most of the charting
libraries nowadays are based on d3 most
of the visualization C's on the web are
based on d3 and interestingly enough
there's only one d3 there's not like 101
different versions of d3 competing for
your attention so clearly something
different is happening here by the way
this timer is not working just wave when
I've got like three minutes so it turns
out d3 has a lot of examples we'll take
a look at a few here is a scatter plot
here's a line chart here's a bar chart
here's an area chart so you might say
okay put
this all together I guess d3 is a
charting library which is kind of weird
though because why would you be building
charting libraries out of charting
libraries and you look some more and you
find there's some crazy like cluster
layout there's a thing of congressional
influences there's who's killing whom in
Game of Thrones and is that Obama's
budget dressed up as the planet Jupiter
so something else is happening here d3
is not just a charting library it's
doing sort of general data
visualizations but what does that really
mean in practice what is it actually and
it turns out it's a Dom manipulation
library now this might seem really
random that your data vis library is
fundamentally a Dom framework but when
you think about it it makes sense what's
unique to data visualization is the data
and then you want to render this data in
some way so you could start with like a
blank slate and you could invent some
totally new technology or maybe use
canvas but you already have these three
guys HTML CSS and SVG and they're your
pals you know how to use them so why
reinvent the wheel let's just find some
way to get the data and have it come
hang with the rest of this crew
and that's exactly what d3 does it lets
you take some data you're going to
create a correspondence between this
data and a bunch of dom nodes
maybe those nodes are SVG circles and
then since you have this mapping you're
just going to use functions to project
properties from your data into visual
attributes so let's see it in action
we've got this whoops
rather this is very low-level as you may
have noticed and as a consequence of
being very low-level it makes incredible
things possible you can basically do
anything you imagine but there's a
trade-off and that trade-off is that d3
make simple things kind of hard and to
see this principle in action we'll take
a look of a scatter plot it's a
straightforward chart it's got a couple
pieces it's got some data it's got an
SVG it's got some scales now if you're
not familiar what a scale is is it just
creates a correspondence between where
the data is and what pixel it should go
to or what general property
and then we're going to some axes that
visualize the scales we're going to have
some labels some the plot itself a
legend all seems reasonable so let's
take a look at the code for the data
we're just going to do some sort of
basic clean-up on it it came in a string
if we want to make it numbers for the
SVG we do some pixel math it's like
we've got to figure out the margins and
then we've got to set up the SVG
according to those margins scales we're
going to get the scales that d3 provides
but then we're going to have to set them
up and configure them and so forth axes
we again get like this axis generating
function from d3 and then we set up some
part of the DOM and then we call this
axis generator so a little bit obtuse
then labels we have to do a lot more
work now we've got to do pixel shifts
we've got to do SVG text anchor
properties it's kind of messy the plot
is where things get really interesting
you might imagine that since the plot is
both the biggest part of the chart and
the part where all the actual action
happens that is correspondingly going to
be a lot of code but it actually is
quite concise and this code is really
neat so we'll just dig into a bit we
have first we're going to select the
part of the SVG we're going to put our
data into it we're going to create a
circle for every piece of data then
we're going to give each circle class
we're going to set a radius and for the
exposition we're going to use a property
of the data and the X scale to determine
where it goes and we do a similar thing
with Y and with fill so what you might
notice about this is a few things first
every line of this code is purposeful
and interesting every line corresponds
to something we really wanted to do it's
no like weird setup here and second it
is really flexible like in this case we
made a scatterplot but you can imagine
that we could have done anything with an
approach this low-level so the plot is
really where d3 shines
unfortunately the legend is a different
story you might say okay this legend is
very simple it's just three pieces of
text it's just three rectangles it's
going to be very straightforward and
it's not really what we have here is a
mess we're going to like put in the data
we're going to create a bunch of G's and
move them around pixel math we're going
to create a bunch of rectangles and we
have to set again pixel math we're going
to create some text we've got some more
hard-coded pixel constants we've got
some more SVG text specification and
finally we're going to put in the actual
text so this really showcases both the
the strengths and weaknesses of d3 the
strengths being when we wanted to
actually just make something purely
based on our data it was incredible but
when we wanted to make a legend or do
any kind of layout it's a little bit
like writing a website in the free
jQuery days using just the raw Dom API
it's not impossible but it is a huge
pain so now that we've understood this
scatterplot we can go through the other
3d three examples pretty quickly and
really just to understand what's going
on and wait that's not a line chart what
are these otters doing in my
presentation that's where you just leave
your keynote attended for three minutes
and this happens too but it is pretty
well that they're stacking cups and I
wish that making d3 charts for more like
that I would use the spare time to hang
out with my friends so since those 30
seconds are never coming back let's not
go through all the charts let's just
look for salvation in the form of other
charting libraries here's a chart that
c3j s makes and it looks pretty much
exactly the same but when we look at the
code it fits all in one slide and it's
pretty straightforward we've got like
okay we're going to create this JSON
Options bag and we're going to pass it
in it'll have some properties like what
are the x-series names what are the data
what type of chart do we want
it's a scatter chart we're going to
configure the axes a little bit and we
can see this is very readable it's very
straightforward and it's not the only
one that will do this there's env d3 and
it's got a kind of a similar approach
we're going to get this scatter chart
model we're going to do some
configuration on it
and we're going to get the chart so okay
we found two good solutions in both
cases we didn't have to do any weird
text mucking we just got the chart we
wanted so this is great right maybe we
can just go home but we haven't really
figured out this lingering mystery of
like why are we doing this over and over
if it's so easy surely we would have
just figured out okay those two
libraries are good enough let's move on
with our lives so what would be really
great at this point is if another
library would go ahead and in addition
to making a new charting library would
explain like okay guys we know there are
hundreds of charting libraries here's
why we felt we had to make another and
Chartist in addition to having a really
awesome logo does just that
they say you may think this is just
another JavaScript charting library but
Chartist was made by a community that
was disappointed with the abilities of
other charting libraries there was
always some kind of tweak you wished for
that wasn't included and this turns out
to be really a fundamental limitation of
this sort of declarative make a whole
chart from a specification approach
because this is really great if the
chart you want to make happens to look
exactly like this one
but let's say we wanted to do something
weird let's say we wanted like two
subplots and variable numbers of axes on
each subplot and one is a scatter plot
and one is like an area chart you can
easily imagine this coming up we'll call
it our super-secret special chart and I
looked in the API here and there's no
flag for turn on super-secret special
chart so we're basically screwed
and unfortunately Welch artist has done
a good job of identifying the problem
they also produced a API declarative
spec and they're also going to run into
the same issues so what we're seeing
here is not that the creators of all
these charting libraries are idiots they
are very smart developers and this is
not easy to do but what is happening is
every library offers a different mix of
like twelve features that are really
nice to have and every consumer has a
different mix of twelve features that
they would really like and for every
person no charting library is like quite
there so they see this and they're like
okay I know what to do I'll just make a
new charting library
all those bright features and then this
will just solve the problem and the
result is that they've made the hundred
and second charting library basically
it's a trap so this seems this gives
point as in any in the presentation for
me to introduce myself my name is Dan
Monday I work with a cool dude named
Justin LAN at a company called Palantir
here's a picture that's me that's Justin
and there's a flying rose and giant
cupcake and an inflatable dinosaur and a
hedgehog so there are some weird things
going on in this picture but when we're
not taking goofy Valentine's Day
pictures we're trying to solve a lot of
different problems sometimes it's
helping areas recover after disasters
such as a tsunami in the Philippines
sometimes it's improving drug discovery
processes sometimes it's just making
sure that supermarkets in Japan keep
their shelves stocked with Pocky what
these problems do all have in common is
data you want to be able to work with
lots and lots of data and that means at
some point you're going to want to make
visualizations and in today's world that
means javascript charting libraries so
when Justin and I were asked to figure
out a path forward for Palantir like how
should we be making these visualizations
across the company we first looked at
the JavaScript charting libraries but it
was clear first of all we had one
feature we really wanted which is
interactive dragon zoom that none of
these libraries had it was our you know
oh we should just make a library to do
this moment but second we have literally
a whole laboratory of designers coming
up with kind of zany visualization ideas
and if we go to them and say okay here
are the 12 charts we're ever going to
make for you they will not be happy with
us and we could use pure d3 and we've
done that before and it works but we
know from experience that means that for
ages to come
Palance you're devs will be forced to
spend their time worrying about like why
is the axis off by one pixel in Internet
Explorer and find in every other browser
and then they're really not solving
those problems that we would really like
solved so the question was can we find a
sweet spot something that exposes the
power and flexibility of d3 but also has
some of the convenience of using a
charting light
and spoiler alert I think that we did it
it's called plottable
it is built on d3 and tries to extend
the d3 philosophy where ever possible
it's written in typescript which is
awesome by the way you should come ask
him about it later if you're curious and
it's hosted on github now I could talk
for a little while about the philosophy
of the library and kind of like Socrates
pontificate while you look away fall
asleep or bang your head and disgust but
instead we'll just jump to some examples
so here's our old friend the d3 scatter
chart and here's our new friend the
plottable scatter plot and we'll just
compare the two so d3 we had to do some
data munging plottable is just going to
handle that for you d3 we had to do a
lot of SVG set up some pixel math
plottable is just going to handle it for
you d3 we made the skills we needed to
configure them plottable just make the
scales they'll auto configure but you
have all the same api points if you want
something special d3 we have to do a lot
of work for the axes plottable we just
get the axes and d3 the labels will be
read plot a bold simple but when we come
to the plot this is the interesting part
right because we actually loved what d3
was doing here pretty much every line of
code was good
so if laudable is just one line here
then it means we've fallen into the trap
of providing no flexibility and the
plottable invocation is actually almost
exactly the same
all of these api points we cared about
are being revealed directly the only
thing that's hidden is the fact that
we're setting up circles is encapsulated
within the scatter plot constructor and
then of course the legend which was a
huge mess of code becomes just one line
now you may be asking ok well I've been
paying close attention and you never
setup the layout of this plottable chart
so what's the deal with that
is it magic am I going to have to ask
Albus Dumbledore how my charge is
getting put together no it's just a
layout engine it's based on two concepts
one is that you can merge different
pieces together and one is that you can
align them in a table the table turns
out to be a really convenient
abstraction for representing charts
because it represents the constraint
that different pieces need to align to
each other in this case the axes need to
stay aligned to the plot
and it's also easy to represent in code
and kind of easy to visualize how your
chart will turn out just by looking at
the JavaScript so we can see that we
kept the strengths of d3 that we really
liked namely the the power over the plot
and all of these weaknesses are gone now
you may say okay that's great that you
can make this scatter plot but we've
already seen that other libraries can
also make the exact same scatter plot so
this is not really showing off any
flexibility so we'll have another
example suppose you have a really kind
of annoying customer not that those
exists or whatever and you a want a bar
chart that is going to show the amount
of rain in three different cities in
California so you're like okay that's
straightforward plottable provides me
with this clustered bar plot and I'll
just set it up and I'm sure they'll be
happy and you go to them and they say no
no no you've completely misunderstood us
yet again we didn't want a clustered bar
chart we wanted three bar plots
vertically stacked on top of each other
so that we can easily see the difference
from each series luckily that's just the
table so we just lay out another table
and we have this like crazy chart and
maybe they say okay well that's good but
we want the SVG to be bigger we want all
the font sizes to be bigger and most
importantly it all needs to be in Comic
Sans now this is going to look terrible
but you don't need to break out your
abacus to do pixel math you just change
the CSS and you get this like really
ugly chart ah but let's not do that so
we'll go back to our original chart and
maybe you know they want some grid lines
you just make some grid lines you merge
them and it's simple
maybe they want to add animations so you
can just set animation to true and you
get these animations but I'll note that
the animator just sets the default
animator it exposes the full d3 API for
creating custom animations and
transitions maybe you know they want to
change over two line plots you can just
do that maybe they want to use a super
sweet plottable time axis you can just
do that maybe they want to merge it all
back together into one plot you just do
it change the grid lines a bit
add interactive pan and zoom why not so
the net result here is we were able to
create like this chart and we weren't
able to just create it but we were able
to iterate really quickly on lots of
different ideas it's probably an order
of magnitude faster than working in pure
d3 so if I were giving this presentation
a week ago this would be the end but
during a dry run some friends were like
well if you've made this library of
chart components why don't you build a
simple charting library out of it
it'll be really easy to use and then
it'll provide a sort of path back into
plottable for people who get into it so
I had this long plane ride to get here
to Berlin so I was like okay sure and
built chart agra fir
it's basically plottable and easy mode a
couple invocation spa a couple
invitations follow in every case setting
up the chart itself is just one line and
then we configure some labels and render
it in the other lines so it's super
super super simple to use but what's
interesting about this is a it's API is
practically non-existent it only gives
you these charts and B it has a path to
flexibility because rather than trying
to be a charting library that does it
all it just has this call called
get components and when you call get
components it will give you all the
plottable pieces and you can swap them
or like twiddle with them or put a new
one to do whatever you please with it so
this enables a new workflow for
developing charts you can start with
chart agra fur it will be incredibly
simple 30 seconds and you have your
chart you'll very quickly want to change
it and then you can just drop down into
plottable and now you know every five
minutes you can be trying out a new
layout and then maybe you discover that
you want some super special fancy data
visualization piece that we don't
already have well then you can just drop
down to d3
write a plugin and you've got your chart
and hopefully you submit it back to us
because then other people can benefit
from your awesome plugin so now comes
the moment in the presentation that you
all didn't know you were waiting for
which is Internet's patience
so that was a clip from a video game
called EVE Online which is known for
being a mix of spaceships and
spreadsheets and as we all know a
spreadsheet really means someone out
there is crying out for some data
visualization so you can see this great
so we're going to go to palatable jets
and check out this example because it's
kind of neat so what we have here is a
chart that is showing off a couple
things about plottable one is showing
off that my design skills are not very
good to begin with and at 5:00 a.m. in
the morning they're even worse ah -
we're seeing that we can handle highly
dimensional data so each circle
represents a spaceship its color is what
race I just have curiosity how many
people here have played Eve at some
point ok smattering
well basically every circle here is a
spaceship we can see its color is
representing what faction built it it's
radius is showing what kind of ship it
is like is it a frigate a battleship and
so forth its stroke is showing us what
like class identity it is and its X&Y
positions or showing how much shield and
how much armor it has so this allows us
to very quickly pick out trends that I
existed in high dimensions so like the
fact that all these faction ships tend
to have much better stats am our ships
tend to have more armor Caldari ships
tend to have more shields and I actually
got this data source from some person
who had done it by hand and as soon as I
put it into plottable I saw all of these
typos where things just like we're not
fitting the pattern
it also has tooltips this is not
actually a feature in plottable yet but
because it's just the three you can just
set them up the way you would in d3
using other libraries and it has this
nifty pan and zoom now the interesting
thing about this chart is that in my
mind it is incomplete I want I think we
should have a legend that shows stroke
rather than just filling in the whole
bubble if people are going to do this
more often and I think that we should
have another legend that's going to show
different radii of thing and like how
our radius corresponds to data so maybe
this is where you come in because the
whole point of plottable
is that it's very modular that is very
pluggable and should be easy for other
people to work with
so maybe one of you guys will just you
know head over to our github and take a
look at the code and you can just write
these legend pieces and then everyone
will be able to use them because I think
that is the path forward out of this
mess of 105 charting libraries we need
to stop independently building totally
separate things that don't interoperate
instead what we need to do is we need to
find one API that is sufficiently
expressive to cover lots of use cases
and then work together to build all of
the pieces so somebody a year from now
can just like trivially throw together
the chart they want and get back to
saving the world or hanging out at the
aquarium with otters or whatever it is
that they want to do so I think this is
actually the real end of my talk let's
see if I have any more slides hiding
nope
so my name is Denae you can find me on
pretty much any service you'd want to
find me as at danman a more importantly
you can find the website for plottable
here at plottable jazz org and you can
fork the source and that's all but since
I have a minute in 20 seconds I'll take
at least one question if anyone wants to
ask I'll take that as a sign that my
claw slideshow is so conclusive that
you're just downloading plottable right
now and like I don't have time for
questions all right thank you guys